entre eric zemmour et le csa c'est loin
d'être une histoire d'amour depuis
plusieurs années le polémiste est dans
la ligne de mire du conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
chaque dérapage le journaliste était
trié comme en 2010 lorsqu'il avait tenu
des propos liant immigration et
délinquance chez thierry ardisson la
plupart des trafiquants
à l'époque il avait été condamné à 2000
euros d'amendé avec sursis pour
provocation à la haine raciale en 2016
c'est pour des propos sur les musulmans
dans ses tabous il est condamné il faut
leur donner le choix entre l'islam et la
france depuis 2010 9 me quotidiennement
sur la chaîne info ses news
oui mais pas autour de l'actualité et
des bas qui lui valent également des
signalements au csa ils sont voleurs ils
sont assassins il son violeur c'est tout
ce qu'ils sont hier la chaîne ces news a
été condamné à payer 200 mille euros
d'amendé pour avoir laisser de tels
propos est retenu sur son antenne
il est naturel que les débats qui
traversent la société trouvent toute
leur place dans les médias audiovisuels
néanmoins la loi fixe des limites à
l'exercice de cette liberté
une sanction que le groupe canal a
contesté en déplorant le principe de
liberté d'expression cette décision
contrevient au principe de liberté
d'expression et le groupe canal compte
mettre en oeuvre les voies de recours
possibles dans les plus brefs délais une
décision qui a fait beaucoup réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux
une chose est sûre depuis des
le csa est particulièrement réactif et
virulent quand il s'agit des propos du
journaliste alors deux cent mille euros
damende pour eric zemmour la sanction
est elle méritée
la sanction est elle méritée on va au ce
que voulait qu'on revoie l'extrait des
rangs pour lequel il a été condamné à
200 mille euros d'amendé
oui qui veut le voir il faut le voir
voilà il vous renverser la table
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que ces jeunes
comme le reste de l'immigration à tous
ne viennent plus tous tous tous
christine tous pourquoi mais parce
qu'ils n'ont rien à faire ici je vous le
répète et c'est son fils sont ils sont
ils sont voleurs ils sont assassins ils
sont violeur c'est tout ce qu'ils sont
il faut les renvoyer attendait il faut
même pas qu'ils viennent ceux qui sont
violents non non entre estime qu'il ne
faut pas se donner le choix il faut en
en laisser entrer personne
alors bon wagon tombe bien sûr eric
zemmour et raquel garrido dans un
instant je me doute de leur position
tous les deux surtout raquel vous dit
non
delphine ben oui eric zemmour c'est un
c'est un polémiste
donc il est connu pour ça il ya même des
personnes qui se pose la question est-ce
qu'il serait pas bon en tant que
politique tellement généralement dans le
flux il parle quand même très bien il va
au bout de certaines idées même si on
n'est pas d'accord avec les idées il il
permet aux gens de réfléchir
donc c'est un polémiste et parfois il
est sur le fil parfois il tombe du film
mary jean on n'est pas d'accord avec
voilà moi je dis non mais je suis pas
sûr du tout sur ce même terrain que toi
moi laquelle la question que je pose
c'est pourquoi le csa infligé cette
amende à ces news - ce que dirait xénon
pour moi n'a aucun sens est vraiment
voilà je suis absolument absolument mais
pas du tout d'accord avec ce qu'il dit
et mais en revanche qu est-ce qui a
notifié qu'est ce qui est assez justifié
deux cent mille euros d'amendé 10 qui
avait pas de contradicteur et disent que
christine kelly en gros n'a pas fait le
job
moi je trouve que christine kelly a fait
le job donc voila et les contradicteurs
elle elle a joué le rôle de
contradicteur et par ailleurs je
m'interroge pourquoi sur ses news
on prend deux cent mille euros pourquoi
sur lci quand on diffuse in extenso la
convention de la droite il ya un rappel
à l'ordre
il n'y a pas de sanction fini chez un
autre lieu un autre moment très dur sur
l'afrique sur lci qu'il était inquiet
pas été sanctionnés donc parler de ceux
sur les sur le court que sur le co vide
oui voilà où c'est que c'est vraiment
pour moi ou il faut les en fait tester
les vaccins en afrique ici à leurs
cobayes mal
le délirant qui normalement sont je suis
là en l'occurrence eric zemmour était
sur lci et est sûre ces news également
et donc là je prends vraiment le même
cas de figure c'est à dire que là on a
reproché aussi à lci
c'est vrai le manque de c'est la même
personne d'eric ses traducteurs et la
manque de maîtrise de l'antenne et pas
de 200000 euros enfin c'est pas les
mêmes voilà sa séance à venir
voilà ça c'est très intéressant ce que
dit valérie parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai eu eric zemmour sur lci salle les
2000 à katyn sur notre histoire
nationale c'était ça il fait un tollé
beaucoup c'est à droite sans que que ce
qu'on voit là et qui est inadmissible ce
que dit voilà eric zemmour mais zéro
sanctions 0 sanctionné là il a deux cent
mille euros c'est quand même tout ça
même si vous êtes d'accord avec cette
sanction
gilles c'est vrai que c'est quand même
il ya deux poids deux mesures je
souscris totalement et je pense qu'elle
sait aurait dû être sanctionné et
lourdement
bon là ce qu'est ce qui ce qui fait que
la sanction selon moi est méritée c'est
aussi que l'émission n'était pas en
direct dès que la chaîne aurait pu
éventuellement coupé après mois sur les
propos je pense qu'il faut sanctionner
effectivement j'aurais préféré qu'il
soit sanctionné lui directement c'est
parce que ses traits et non pas vraiment
je sais mais du coup je pense quand même
que la chaîne doit être sanctionné ne
serait-ce que tanière symbole si vous
vous dit une bêtise c'est où le produit
qui va être diffusé ou le diffuseur
oui je préférerais que ce soit le dif
est attendue voilà pour des raisons qui
m'incombe bernard montiel
non moi je trouve qu évidemment il ya un
gros problème grave problème des mineurs
isolés seulement glace tout ce qu'il a
dit c'est une incitation à la haine et
de la discrimination il a encore remis
les migrations sur le tapis il a les
mêmes thèses qui sont quand même pénible
il est extrêmement brillant ce monsieur
c'est dommage qu'ils pensent de ce côté
là qui est insupportable et la star moi
je voudrais revenir sur ce cas ni
valérie le csa dit que christine kelly
n'a pas fait ce rôle de quinn et elle me
dit pas tout ce temps il lui a même re
dix derrière et oui parce qu'une guerre
à la fsa à la fin de la séquence à la
même préciser qu'i s'exprimer en son
seul nom exact elle a immédiatement
désolidarisé de la chaîne de lui mais
attendez c'est jusqu'au décida le
dossier jamais cessé c'est justement ce
qui est très grave et à france
télévisions quand il était en deuxième
partie de soirée à l'époque il y avait
temps en temps des dérapages celui qui
était repris remier remis dans ce
contexte c'était eric zemmour s'était
pas la chaîne
donc un moment donné ça veut dire quoi
que christine kelly n'a pas de rôle dans
cette émission ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose qu'elle ne maîtrise
pas l'antenne ce qui est complètement
faux puisque effectivement et a rappelé
à l'ordre vendredi en disant ce sont vos
paroles
donc ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
comment on peut attaquer c'est nous qui
pour moi n'a rien à voir là dedans je
veux dire la maîtrise de l'antenne il
n'y aurait pas eu de maîtrise de
l'antenne c'est complètement faux donc
ça devient dangereux parce que ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui on pourra attaquer
n'importe quelle chaîne pour des propos
de même deux chroniqueurs et eric un mot
sur la forme mais un mot sur le fond sur
la forme
en effet un peu plus tard dans
l'émission eric zemmour fait plus que
nuancé ses propos il reconnaît qu'il a
été trop loin en fait ils n'ont pas tous
t'ont pourquoi le csa ne prend en compte
qu'une partie des déclarations de ces
mots pourquoi que le début de ces
déclarations est pas la fin ensuite sur
le fond maintenant les décisions du csa
ca sert a enterré les problèmes c'est à
dire que évidemment que je sais pas tous
les mineurs isolés mais il ya une partie
des mineurs isolés qui pose des
problèmes de délinquance très gras vous
pouvez en parler avec certains riverains
parisien est aussi des très belles
histoires qui se passe avec mineurs
isolés qui trouvent leur place dans la
société française mais il n'empêche que
c'est un vrai problème
or maintenant on refuse maintenant de
discuter sur le fond tout se passe sur
la forme vous dérapez on coupe votre
intervention un certain moment on vous
sanctionne et plus personne ne parle de
ce que zemmour selon moi a soulevé à
juste titre mais dans un premier temps
de manière que qui évidemment
inadmissible
mais prenons au la globalité de ses
déclarations je comprends pas ce deux
poids deux mesures entre le début de
l'émission à la fin de l'émission un
calgary dont vous pensez que c'est 2000
les deux cent mille euros damende son
mérite est oui
et j'aimerais rappeler pourquoi le csa
tout simplement se positionne c'est
parce qu'en france tout le monde n'a pas
le droit d'émettre sur une onde radio /
etc c'est pourquoi le séisme alors ça
c'est autre chose si on fait un appel
tous commun ici pour quelle série g à
des régies souscrit mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que la chaîne ces news a
signé une convention avec le csa et je
suis allé par acquis de conscience
lire cette convention et on y trouve et
c'est signé par serge ménard au nom de
ses news
il a écrit ses nuits donc c'est mieux
g alors j'ai découvert qu'ils avaient
même cet engagement là à respecter les
différentes sensibilités politiques
culturelles et religieuses du public
non pardon et mourra a une obsession
non mais là dessus eric zemmour est dans
le bas de l'ensemble de la chaîne
oui j'ai de la question qui est posée
c'est à l'occasion de ses émissions de
zemmour et cette émission en particulier
est ce que là est ce que la chaîne a
respecté ses engagements qui ont été
signés c'est pas moi raquel garrido qui
a pris ces engagements là c'est serge
années déjà bon allez on le prend sur
ses cages et d'hermine nuggets
encourager les comportements
discriminatoires en raison de la race ou
de l'origine du sexe l'orientation
sexuelle de la région de religion pardon
ou la nationalité quand on s'observe sur
les immigrés est ce que c'est pas une
discrimination sur la nationalité c'est
précisément ça donc là il ya un problème
si vous voulez entre des obligations qui
en fait un combat l'audiovisuel en
général et à chaque chaîne en
particulier et qui ensuite se
matérialise dans des conventions qui
seront signées par les chaînes lorsque
ces conventions sont pas respectées il
ya des mises en demeure et un truc
graduée on y va petit à petit d'abord en
dire assez mal et après on reprend saint
pée les sourcils et après on monte en
bon ton monte
hélas le csa d'échapper au portefeuille
c'est vrai que grecque et de sombres ou
six meilleures normandes énormément
darwin y aura qu elle sait pas une norme
ce qui s'est passé la preuve c'est que
cette sanction est inédite c'est la
première fois qu'une femme est condamnée
financièrement pour des propos qui ont
été tenus sur son antenne cgem arrivé
avant c'est ça en france y est un droit
qui s'appelle la liberté d'expression
ces news et toutes les chartes et permet
les opinions des jeunes enfants je ne
comprends pas sinon ça veut dire quoi à
chaque fois qu'ils aient des propos
polémiques
on va demander de payer on va demander
aux chaînes de payer c'est n'importe
quoi ça va assez petit et le débat c'est
tout oui isabelle moi je trouve que eric
a soulevé un point extrêmement important
c'est déjà celui dont on a parlé hier
pour un autre sujet c'est à savoir le
fait qu'on isole le propos d'une donne
discours général est effectivement à la
fin il a nuancé son propos il a dit je
suis allé trouver mais quand bien même
la turquie du problème oui oui non mais
c'est non mais c'est sûr il
il a nuancé son propos après mais bon le
csa ils ont eu des plaintes là dessus et
ils ont soit le seul truc c'est que je
trouve que christine kelly a bien fait
son travail elle
mais moi je comprends pas qu'est ce
qu'on retire à la fin de tous les propos
d'eric zemmour c'est pas un propos
discriminatoires il dit il y a en fait
c'est sa conclusion est qu'il y ait un
problème avec certains mineurs isolés
qui ici peut dire le contraire
voilà ce que moi j'ai retenu de cette
émission il a eu une expression trop
vivre trop radin mais on était au début
il a dit ou visionner le cjb rebelles
alors je voudrais quand même dire
quelque chose d'abord effectivement
quand vous l'avez dit même si vous
nuancé vous l'avez dit mais je voulais
dire c'est quand même quelque chose pour
revenir sur le deux poids deux mesures
et raquel parlait d'une convention il
faut pas être dupe quand même eric
zemmour aujourd'hui ils dérangent ils
dérangent et la chaîne aussi il dérange
le pouvoir et c'est pas un hasard non
plus il faut pas qu'on soit des voitures
c'est pas hasard non plus si le csa
aujourd'hui qui est quand même une voix
officielle une une organisation
institutionnelle tape sur ses new skies
dérange c'est pour ça qu'ils ont signés
sur lci on pas taper sur essais
hivernaux au moment de la capture et
s'est hissé aux demandes qui est une
unité axe que c'est la même personne en
plus ce qui est inscrit mais que ce soit
sur un séisme ou sur ces news comme par
hasard elle si ils prennent juste un
rappel à l'ordre et ses mousses une
sanction
incroyable de 200000 euros et politique
les jeux vous dire les propos d'eric
zemmour ici on les a toujours dénoncé
oui on a toujours été contre ces propos
après on est ce contre ces propos que ce
soit sur lci où que ce soit sur
saignement là aussi les rails il arrive
demain sur equidia voilà donc non mais
c'est vrai voilà si ceci près que eric
zemmour comme il a été condamné en des
chaussures que témoin on passa dans la
porte
oui mais oui même il a été condamné
plusieurs noms mais il est deux poids
deux mesures oui mais il ya quand même
comment dire que quelqu'un qui vole dans
un magasin d peut pas dire au juge oui
mais mon voisin aussi la volée ça marche
pas devant le juge eric zemmour sur lci
mais les obligations elle incombe à la
chaîne lui répond de ses paroles devant
la justice devant la dix septième
chambre delà du tribunal correctionnel à
paris les chaînes elles répondent devant
le csa voilà c'est moi l'année et sylla
et si ces news veut faire du business
entre ses évolue sur sa droite mais elle
sait ils font quoi
bah oui donc voila moi je crois que ça
me dérange at il s'en est pris au
portefeuille parce que comme ça cesse et
nous la mesurer entre l'audience que ça
rapporte ça rapporte beaucoup d'audience
de toute cette idée au lc ya pas mal
égard cassé mais les cités à l'audience
avec sa vie moi je suis tout à fait pour
les taper ce qui a été dit sur elle oui
c'est horrible d'accord vous êtes
d'accord avec moi même qu'il y a quand
même un problème avec ces news et que
tout le monde et c'est la société sur
celle où je pense que si eric zemmour
avait fait la même chose sur une autre
chaîne n'y aurait pas eu la même si
certains je vous le 600t que
l'intervention d'eric zemmour sur lci
avait été très très longue
oui là c'est quelques lots dont quelque
chose qui sait pas ce qui s'est passé
sur ntv
même si sur ces nous voilà les propos
sont inadmissibles c'est beaucoup plus
grave que ça suffisait news il ya un
comité d'éthique de bétail abc news a
fait des avertissements qui a dit faites
le tourner en décalé je sais pas mais le
cas échéant ce qui n'a pas été fait si
j'étais coupé jauzion tournant décalé
oui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que avant
du coup
de faire face à cette amende de 200
mille euros
ces news avait déjà eu un genre de
rappel à l'ordre de la part du csa
tout m'a hué mais j'avais déjà vu à
reims en une sorte de rappel à l'ordre
et puis surtout en médiatisant à ce
point eric zemmour fait aussi s'y
attendre aussi ça non à ce qui est ce qu
avait là et l'ambition soir et est
vraiment dure et toi de me dire moi je
suis fait d'accord voilà c'est nicolas
pernikoff vous qui étiez dans les
arcanes du pouvoir
aulas pernikoff est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya quand même un acharnement et
bien sûr qu'il ya un acharnement et
puisqu'il mettait sur ces 11 h parle pas
mais parce que sur les immigrés
attendait alors je vous dis de zemmour
sur les immigrés c'est sûr personne
c'est bon il paraît tous les ans on peut
parler n'importe quoi on va parler du
coville va dire ah ouais mais c'est
parfait ça les immigrés ils ont écrit
les textes il attendait mais c'est à
dire comme un bernard de la villardière
il va faire n'importe quel est le
ferment sur une pharmacie va faire qu'un
l'islam dans les pharmacies mon seuil
est à l'exact même la décision qui a été
prise vous êtes en train de de sortir
complètement je crois qu'eric voulais en
parler d'ailleurs de du contexte
à ce moment là c'est l'auteur de l'
attaque duo à deux choix devant les
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo ou a été
arrêté à la soi-disant mineurs isolés et
vous savez que la seule le seul moyen
aujourd'hui de reconnaître un mineur
isolé c'est de faire un prélèvement
osseux pour connaître son âge qui ce
qu'ils refusent tous et en l'occurrence
il était beaucoup plus âgée et il avait
de ce statut donc de mineurs isolés
donc il faut juste remettre le truc dans
le contexte c'est un peu comme la photo
d'hier c'est à dire que là on est en
train de juste de dire qu'il a dit ça ça
est facturé avec eric naulleau
mais j'aurais juste ajouter une
information de l'intérieur je peux vous
dire que les répercussions de
l'intervention d'eric zemmour à la
convention de la droite on était
beaucoup plus fort assuré - lolo que ce
qu'il a dit sur les mineurs isolés
c'est à dire que le lendemain c'était un
paria beaucoup de gens ne voulaient plus
venir chez moi mais je serais pas venu
c'est quand même étrange que soient
sanctionnées la ferme s'il ya eu le
moins de répercussions le savez bien la
preuve qu'un nombre de mesures je reste
je suis à quelque chose qui ne va pas ça
c'est sûr mais